[Musique]
deux tours à droite pour allumer les
phares côté bling de clignotants gauche
droite norman mais attention il ne
revient pas automatiquement il faut le
remettre après chaque tournant
un son de casserole
du carton dans la carrosserie
pollution optimale
vitesse de croisière 40 km heure
voici la trame entre le fleuron
technologique de la défunte république
démocratique allemande
[Applaudissements]
et
vingt ans après la chute du mur la
trabant tu n'es plus que le vestige
touristique d'un pays disparu
un véhicule exotiques qu'on emprunte en
convoi pour un voyage au temps de la rda
communiste
des vins et ibra diallo passons ici sur
la bande de la mort le long d'une partie
restante du mur
à gauche
à droite bernard est
dès le début des années 60 la trabant
était déjà démodé
iman pourtant beaucoup d'innovations été
testé en secret dans les usines
mais les dirigeants n'ont pas voulu une
tasse mardi fut route et les dirigeants
de rda ne voulait qu'une seule voiture
c'est le top n'avait pas besoin de pouce
[Musique]
après la réunification en a
malheureusement détruit presque tout le
mur il reste trop peu de souvenirs de ce
bon vieux temps tu as arrêté
c ici c'est le plus long bout de mur qui
existent encore
quand je passe devant je me sens un peu
comme autant de l'aisne
ce goût nouveau pour une époque révolue
porte un nom
l'ostalgie la nostalgie de l'est et
l'ostalgie a maintenant son hôtel à
berlin loos tél
[Musique]
39 chambres décorées dans le plus pur
style rda des fleurs jusqu'au papier
peint
[Musique]
un hôtelier de 35 ans daniel helbig qui
cultive le souvenir d'une enfance
heureuse à l'est
[Musique]
cette coiffeuse est tout à fait typique
chaque femme avait la même dans sa
chambre à coucher
nous sommes aussi très fiers d'avoir mis
un poste de radio authentique dans
toutes les chambres radio
[Musique]
voilà lit d'origine très représentatif
du style rda avec son étagère
c'était la rolls royce délit
mais il faut avouer que peu de gens
avaient un portrait d'eric honecker au
dessus de leur lit
ça c'est un clin d'oeil pour les clients
en fait certains le décroche et le coup
dans un coin une équipe steve daniel
helbig agrandi côté privilégié avec les
parents artistes et le droit de voyager
son os tel vent une rda souriante
pour moi le stalles jce le souvenir d'un
pays oubliés
dont on a voulu se débarrasser trop
rapidement se battent des mains et dont
on se rappelle aujourd'hui
je suis ici les gens découvrent un
morceau d'histoire ils peuvent même la
palper
ce n'est pas disneyland rien est factice
tout vient de la rda c'est presque comme
un musée ou un peu de chez nous
[Musique]
la république démocratique allemande fut
pendant 40 ans la vitrine du monde
communiste un pays phare du bloc de
l'est qui s'autoproclamait champion du
développement industriel et de la pureté
idéologique
un pays où régnait la dictature du
prolétariat un état où le parti unique
et ses dirigeants infaillible faisait le
bonheur du peuple
[Musique]
mais un pays prison dont on ne pouvait
sortir librement un peuple enfermé
derrière un mur 17 millions d'habitants
sous surveillance leur fait leur geste
même leurs pensées scrutés par l'oeil
omniprésent de la police politique la
stasi
[Musique]
murs stasi dictature tout s'effondre en
même temps par une nuit de novembre 1989
absorbé par l'allemagne réunifiée la rda
et la perdante de l'histoire sa légende
du mois recommence
sauf qu'à soi-même et stefan füle je
crois qu'on a perdu le convoi
est ce qui place beaucoup de rues ont
changé de nom pareil on a remplacé les
noms des dignitaires communistes parce
de généraux avec les militari
[Musique]
c'est dommage à mon avis il ne fallait
pas tout enlever
[Musique]
et
on peut parler avec des gens de
l'ancienne rda des chauffeurs de taxi
beaucoup se demandent pourquoi il
fallait démolir le palais de la
république par au monde c'était à part
la république à cuver son bébé
elle ne restera bientôt plus rien du
palais de la république le siège du
pouvoir communiste
ce symbole architectural de la dictature
doit disparaître du coeur de berlin
officiellement pour cause d'amiante
on est devant les restes
l'ancien palais de la république
le bâtiment le plus représentatives de
la rd1 condamné à moi au payer pour la
réunification
fred rubine est venu de l'ouest en
sauveur de patrimoine après la
réunification il obtient au culot de
pouvoir récupérer le mobilier du palais
dont personne ne voulait plus il
s'empare alors des luminaires du grand
hall des bureaux des dirigeants du parti
les joyaux de l'esthétique socialiste
tombe entre ses mains d'artistes même le
bar de la cantine des fonctionnaires
tout est en moi
et moi je peux bien imaginer que les
fonctionnaires de l'état à l'époque
ils ont bien pris un petit schnaps cul
sec
autour du bas pour voir mieux et plus
claire le futur
de la rd1
alors j'ai arraché haut des montées
comme on dit le banc j'ai construit une
machine au milieu de ce truc ronde et
la construction est amer monde de monter
le bain et de la tournée pour avoir un
effet du détournement de l'histoire
[Musique]
les lampes du comité central les
lumières du pouvoir communiste recycler
dans le sous sol d'un restaurant
[Musique]
fred robin manie avec dérision les
meubles et les accessoires de la
dictature sa façon de faire sortir de la
crise grâce une certaine allemagne de
l'est
[Musique]
on peut pas avoir du futur quand on n'a
pas le passé quand même on ne peut pas
dire qu'ils aient eu 17 millions d des
allemands de l'est qui ont été des
méchants alors il ya eu quand même une
vie pendant des dizaines d années une
vie qu'on peut pas effacer c'est pas les
lampes qui sont coupables aux saloperies
qui sont arrivés et la mémoire de ce
peuple et on peut pas la jeter dans la
poubelle
la marque de l'est s'inscrit encore dans
la pierre et dans le bronze elle laisse
aussi son empreinte plus profonde
surtout ceux qui sont nés et ont grandi
en rda
a gan corps a longtemps été un enfant
chéri du régime
cet ancien officier de la stasi est
l'homme qui a dessiné le tracé du mur un
mur dont on entretient le terrible
souvenir à checkpoint charlie le plus
célèbre point de passage entre
berlin-ouest et berlin-est
il est par ailleurs ce bâtiment là c'est
celui ci où le petit sourire et semur
ici
ils étaient leurs pattes arrière
la ville d'agde encore se confond avec
le mur
il en est l'historien amateur il en fut
à l'âge de 21 ans le cartographe
officiel il est aux premières loges de
sa construction en août 1961 il vient
alors à checkpoint charlie où la tension
entre l'ouest et l'est menace de
dégénérer en troisième guerre mondiale
[Musique]
ce mur c'était la frontière cette maison
est à l'ouest le trottoir lui est à
l'essai
le 15 août 1961 dans l'après-midi
j'arrive de l'être mais caf
topographiques à l'âme
du cost et berlin ouest il y à des
manifestants il occupe alors me donne
lors notre race henning blanche
pour marquer la frontière centre vers
l'ouest
le pied gauche
une friteuse à l'époque j'étais persuadé
devrait pour la paix contre les méchants
de l'ouest
alors que le mur ne servait qu'à
empêcher les gens d'ici de fuir vers la
bas
mais c'était en 1960 et je n'avais pas
encore eu le déclic
quand ce déclic viendra à gan corps
voudra démissionné de la stasi il
connaît alors la prison puis il est mis
au placard du régime lui-même victime du
monstre qu'il a contribué à créer
sur cette carte est représentée tout le
système du mur du zéro délit cette ligne
rouge c'était la frontière pour les
citoyens de rda
et il y avait 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
sorte de barrière succès 6
toutes différentes pour empêcher les
gens de fuir vers l'ouest la nar fait
une note
[Musique]
un clic j'avais 5 ans à la fin de la
guerre de l'allemagne était complètement
détruit et on nous disait à nous les
enfants que l'ouest c'était le
capitalisme c'était la guerre
voici ce qu'on distribuait alors dans
les boîtes aux lettres
sur ce tract au dos il y à une photo de
moi que ce ciel où je suis le seul en
uniforme il peine à angie l'onu fond uni
et jeu sert de modèle pour inciter les
jeunes à s'engager dans l'armée de r&d
end en pro b c'est dans cet univers que
l'on baigne à l'époque il faut raconter
les choses comme on les a vécus
[Applaudissements]
hague encore l enfant d'un immense
espoir mais d'une immense tragédie
après la seconde guerre mondiale
l'allemagne nazie vaincu est partagée
par les vainqueurs en 1949 la zone
occupée par l'armée rouge que devient un
pays communiste la république
démocratique allemande
[Musique]
oh
aux avant-postes du bloc de l'est face à
un loup est diabolisé ici on croyait
construire la paix la prospérité ici on
bâtissait des lendemains qui chantent
un pays neuf un avenir forcément radieux
un peuple tenu sous le charme par la
propagande et l'enthousiasmé des débuts
la rda a eu son âge d'or
[Musique]
un très simple
ce bon vieux temps de la rda a
aujourd'hui son musée
de l'histoire mise en boîte qui rappelle
ses côtés obscurs qui conserve aussi les
traces laissées par quarante ans d'une
autre vie quotidienne
[Musique]
s'il ne nie pas
c'est une
en
fait c'est un rappel quand je faisais la
cuisine avec ma mort
quand je vois ses couverts là c'est
dommage car on ne peut pas les attraper
mais ils sont tous léger en aluminium
parfois quand on était une cuillère dans
la bouche on prenait d'électricité
tout ça fait revenir le passé ça fait
plaisir
[Musique]
cette rda pour touristes pittoresque et
chatoyantes fait ressurgir un art de
vivre oublié lui aussi balayé en bloc
par la réunification
pourtant derrière le mur l'est savez
parfois fabriqués de mon produit c'est
l'histoire d apple mac les personnages
des feux pour piétons ils avaient
presque tous disparu remplacé par les
signaux de l'ouest
aujourd'hui les ampoules man sont de
retour sous la pression populaire plus
lisible plus sympathique est plus
familier les personnages à chapeaux ont
reconquis les rues de berlin est comme
west
les en pole man font même l'objet d'un
culte ou singulier mélange de réflexes
identitaires et deux déclinaisons
marketing
cette alliance entre le capitalisme est
un produit du socialisme a été initiée
il ya dix ans par marcus aka ozanne
jeunes designers venus de l'ouest il a
su gagner la complicité de carl pglo le
créateur des engueulades
au début ce cher marcus me semblait bien
suspect
je ne voulais pas donner les ampoules
manne pour la publicité
leur place est dans la rue grâce les
techniques avant d'acheter à cause du
nouvel ordre social on les a enlevées
des rues donc pacte chapka
alors j'ai pensé que celui serait
qu'avec son aide avec le design avec la
publicité il pourrait sauver lampe
henman avec les métiers pour qu'il
revienne dans la rue
[Musique]
quand carl pglo a conçu les uns poelman
en 1961 il était psychologiquement les
transports un métier disparu en même
temps que la rda et sa création était
propriété collective
commercialisée c'était un mot inconnu en
r d
nous ont donné les choses où on les
jetait à 4,4 km h on n'avait pas l'idée
de commercialiser un produit vasco même
beau
[Musique]
le succès des ampoules man c'est la
petite revanche d'une moitié d'allemagne
vaincu qui cherche encore sa place dans
l'allemagne d'aujourd'hui
au début on est venu de l'ouest en
imposant nos produits
on disait que tout ce qui était de l'est
pour les gt bon à jeter
langman a été victime de cette mentalité
de vainqueur
a découvert que dans cet autre allemagne
on savait aussi bien travailler et faire
de bonnes choses ingemar parfois même
humanité s amarin
kadhafi a ajouté tom lampes et le mal
n'est pas simplement un symbole de
l'ostalgie zonal symbole il montre qu'on
peut être au même niveau
vu avait tracé une zone d'à mais ce
n'est pas seulement un souvenir du passé
il montre qu'on peut aller ensemble vers
l'avenir sous comme frais
la rda communiste mettait en avant ses
performances industrielles elle se
voulait alors légales de l'ouest avec sa
télévision en couleurs et même de la
publicité pour ses produits vedettes
[Applaudissements]
line fugue la route et florine a
écrit sa benne de très hautes hélas
toujours tomber
[Musique]
cauchemar
florine à quai on sait fut mon épaule
avant
voici le produit dès qu'il existait du
temps de la rda re avec son extrait de
camomille anti inflammatoires
ce produit était très prisé et j'ai moi
même utiliser cette crème pour mes
enfants quand il était petit ça marche
si contre les rougeurs et comme à
l'époque il n'y avait pas de produits
spéciaux pour les bébés je prenais ça
pour mes enfants
ils ont grandi avec cette crème
la crème de beauté florennes à un
produit plus vieux que la rda est l'un
des rares qui lui survivent après avoir
failli disparaître la marque connaît
aujourd'hui une seconde vie relancé par
des capitaux privés une gamme élargie à
un même site de production mais
modernisées
evelyne yonne travail schaeffler et n'a
depuis 1975 elle a traversé les deux
époques elle a connu ce temps où les
ouvriers étaient les héros affiché du
régime où il n'y avait officiellement
pas de chômage ou l' usine était le
foyer obligé de la vie socialiste
tout n'était pas aussi automatisé à
l'époque beaucoup de travail se faisait
manuellement c'était éprouvant
physiquement
mais il y avait un plus grand sens de la
solidarité entre collègues
ça c'était formidable
du temps de la rda ont été organisés en
brigades et grâce à ces brigades on
faisait plein de choses ensemble en
dehors du travail
[Applaudissements]
l'embrigadement renier et démantelé l'ès
20 ans après le regret d'une vie plus
convivial fait sport sorties toutes été
consignés par les brigades dans leur
registre annuel beaucoup de ces livres
ont été jetés evelyne yonne a exhumé les
derniers de chez flore et n'a
[Applaudissements]
manqué beaucoup de choses en ce temps là
mais quand je feuillette ce livre je me
rends compte que ce n'était pas
uniquement un teint de pénurie
c'était aussi une belle époque
où tout n'était pas si mauvais mais
jallet schlecht
le 8 mars la journée de la femme parce
que ça n'existe plus vraiment il y à
bien la journée internationale de la
femme mais on ne la fait plus de la même
façon les femmes ne sont plus honorer
comme avant
il
faut que les fans du fric frac
avant dans la rda de sa jeunesse la
femme était l'égal de l'homme est
parfois plus neuf sur dix travaille est
il y avait des crèches pour leurs
enfants du temps pour les loisirs
une époque douillette qui se termine
avec la chute du mur en novembre 89 une
date ou s'interrompt aussi le livre de
la brigade
[Musique]
sur la dernière page et il ya un article
sur le droit nouveau de voyager
et là quelqu'un a écrit
on discute tous les jours de l'actualité
on se sent tous concernés par ces
problèmes
vu comment cela va-t-il continuer brass
band une caisse qui nous attend
et voilà la fin du livre de la brigade
après malheureusement il n'y a plus rien
nous les citoyens de l'ex rda nous avons
peut-être fait des erreurs à cause de la
curiosité
ainsi on s'est demandé si la lessive de
l'ouest il avait vraiment plus blanc
comme la pub le disait alors on l'a
achetée et on a jeté la nôtre mais
quelques années plus tard moi j'ai
repris mon ancienne et je m'occupais
[Musique]
cette fois ci le mixeur rg 28 tennis et
tout le monde avait sa chez soi c'était
le mixeur que les ménagères utilisé il
pourrait durer jusqu'à 30 ans un autre
morceau d'histoire un vrai classique
son odeur est à la bourre couleurs
premier jour d'école il ne me reste plus
que trois quand je les aurais vendu je
n'en n'aurai plus à des scènes ce
coffret sont encore le parfum de
l'époque
[Musique]
infectés ou le casque bergeyck fabriqués
à berlin dans sa version luxe
magazine ta santé c'est parce qu'en
regard des arts en buvez banque td à
bordeaux
phillies atypique appliqué ici aux
lecteurs de diapos ce qui a choqué
rythmant
les années après voilà la radio fonds
offrait pour la cérémonie d'entrée dans
la jeunesse socialiste
pour garder ça coûtait 700 marques alors
qu'un mois de loyer coûté 70 26
septembre pour la radio 70 marques pour
le loyer kate et aujourd'hui ça vaut 40
euros
tout était au même prix de rostock à
berlin
une production unit for un prêt unis il
y avait toujours des pièces détachées
ont réparé tout on ne jetez rien c'était
trop précieux
cette veste vient du palais de la
république
c'est l'uniforme du personnel à l'astral
au crime par le problème c'est que je ne
peux pas la lave et
sinon elle se déforme et la couleur
disparaît
c'est ça la qualité après tant d'années
le magasin de mario schuberth et comme
le musée de son enfance il n'avait que
15 ans prend le mur est tombé
[Musique]
c'est rda natale était un monde où l'on
pouvait grandir heureux malgré ses
magasins vides ces pénuries chroniques
sa technologie désuète et ses objets de
pacotille
[Musique]
un monde qui ignorait encore les
bienfaits de la société de consommation
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le palais de la république en forme au
bar
le lego de la r d un
autre grand classique une pièce rare
dans mon village sur 7000 habitants avec
que le fils du boulanger qui en avaient
été tous les jours il y avait 25
personnes chez lui j'ai joué des nuits
entières
on était obligés d'être ensemble c'est
vrai mais les liens étaient plus étroit
aujourd'hui tout est plus égoïste
c'est chacun pour soi
ça me manque un peu cette vie en
communauté
l'époux dix c'était le groupe officiel
la bande-son de la vie quotidienne
[Musique]
l'époux 10 5 garçons dans le vent d'est
un groupe né dans les sixties en même
temps que les rolling stones et johnny
hallyday formés dans les écoles de
musique du régime les + 10 ont gagné
leurs galons de star au bout de leurs
guitares idole des jeunes de rda
rebelles aux cheveux longs mais aussi
des sages ils furent le premier groupe
autorisé à se produire à l'ouest et à
exporter le son rock du monde communiste
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les poux dix sont toujours
là et ils se sentent aussi libres qu'ils
n'ont été au bon vieux temps de l'est
tout le monde était plus ou moins livre
même si la plupart n'avaient pas le
droit de quitter le pays pour mais on
n'était pas contrôlée dans sa vie
quotidienne
on n'était pas toujours obligé de faire
attention à ce qu'on disait c'était pas
si dur que ça
c'est sûr que notre popularité nous a
permis à l'époque de les faire beaucoup
plus de choses que d'autres personnes
nissan va
et puis cette popularité agrandissement
et aujourd'hui encore dit encore bien
trop n'en faut
qu'on y est on a un boulot à faire
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
avant à l'est les gens étaient
enthousiastes
mais avec la réunification
ils ont voulu écouter d'autres choses et
puis après ils sont revenus vers nous
ils se sont rendu compte qu'elle est il
y avait de la bonne musique
[Musique]
howarth
à
dans les années 60 et 70
même le mur n'arrête pas la vague
musicale et liberté un venu de l'ouest
[Musique]
la jeunesse communiste de la durenque on
lui donne l époux 10 de la contre
culture intégrée au régime placés à la
tête de la section rock musique du très
officiel comité pour les divertissements
les décorés par des dirigeants
reconnaissance à l'est les voies de la
subversion devait rester impénétrables
[Musique]
nos textes et lyrique philosophique or
100 et je pense que ça faisait bien
et puis rda il y avait des tableaux
tabou ce cas on ne pouvait pas écrire
sur le mur textuellement maman sur
l'environnement mais grâce à nos textes
on pouvait dire qu'ils pas mal de choses
entre les titres
par exemple notre chanson icare ikaros
était synonyme de liberté et d'évasion
ce mode est synonyme de france où notre
premier titre les portes s'ouvrent sur
la ville faisait allusion au porte vers
berlin ouest
à la musi chorales et tous les artistes
ont eu recours à des métaphores
faire passer un message entre les lignes
on n'avait pas le choix on a grandi avec
des ciseaux de censeur dans la tête
comme
grosse et brawn
[Musique]
chaque fois qu'on nous demande ce qui
est différent
or à l'ouest nous disons les impôts
en rda les artistes avaient le privilège
de ne payer que 20 pour cent vingt pour
quelles que soient leurs revenus qui
parle des ferries fatima
ce soir c'était simple et très bien pour
notre siège et nous avons dû nous
habituer à un autre système da pour 10 h
à l'ouest ils sont bien plus malin ce
type s ils savent comment ça fonctionne
et pour nous c'est plus dur fut heureux
de s'associer à
monsieur kim wolfram un autre revenant
le michel drucker de la télévision est
allemande enregistre aujourd'hui ça 323e
émissions dans les rues de dresde
[Musique]
36 ans d'antenne commencé en 1972
poursuivis après la réunification
à la demande du public une popularité
acquise au contact des gens qui
l'interrogent pour répondre aux
questions parfois loufoques du courrier
des téléspectateurs
inoxydable en dessus hakim wolfram
résiste à l'audimat comme il a survécu à
l'ascension politique
pendant 40 ans
1949 89 les gens ont vécu dans ce pays
avec leurs joies
leurs soucis leurs tristesses trouve
entre deux
ça on ne peut pas le ballet
quand on a un compagnon de route pendant
tout ce temps je me considère comme un
compagnon de route sympathique on ne
veut pas le perdre on est content qu'il
soit encore là rod suspense qu on lui
reste fidèle jusqu'à la mort
[Musique]
humour et vie quotidienne
la recette danse yoakim wolfram lui
garantissait une sorte d'immunité
[Musique]
il pouvait se permettre d'intervenir et
mireille mathieu une star de l'ouest
dans les rues de berlin reste comme de
flirter avec les tabous de la propagande
devant les boulangeries y avait toujours
de l'umq ça on ne pouvait pas le montrer
à la télévision
mais un jour quelqu'un nous pose la
question pourquoi le champ canon est il
plus à la mode
alors un matin on s'est rendu devant une
boulangerie où une centaine de personnes
faisait la queue et on les a répartis en
trois groupes pour les faire chanter en
canon
rayé vous
[Musique]
c'était un spectacle incroyable
vous avez eu quelques critiques mais on
a pu tout de même diffusé on dit
les gens en rda savait très bien ce que
l'on voulait dire par là
c'était la même situation qu'au cas
barral il fallait être rusé pour pouvoir
dire ce que l'on voulait
[Musique]
après quarante années de mensonge la rda
continue à dénigrer ses secrets les plus
enfouis
[Musique]
l'idée
fall cause de nice et moritz font partie
d'une association d'habitants qui a
transformé en musée ce bunker abandonné
du jour au lendemain après la
dissolution de l'armée de verdière
ce bon coeur géant quatre niveaux sous
le sol abritait le quartier général du
contrôle aérien militaire
une base ultra secrète cachée dans une
forêt près de la frontière tchèque
[Musique]
il ya un bunker qui n'existait sur
aucune carte officielle sauf celle de la
stasi
[Musique]
c'est la caserne de quel pitre là où se
trouve le bon car
falco de nice et moritz sont nés après
la réunification
ils font revivre une rda qui n'ont pas
connu
au milieu c'est le portrait de voltaire
olbricht le premier ouais le premier
secrétaire du comité central je crois et
à côté
erich honecker on a parlé en faut de ces
gens là à l'école mais le sujet n'a pas
vraiment été traités
[Musique]
consommateurs
en fait on en parle surtout avec nos
grands pas où est
elles nous racontent ce qu'ils ont vécu
et en général il on parle de façon
politique relative positif d'armes à
l'époque il y avait moins de gens très
riches et tous les autres étaient égaux
les richesses étaient distribuées de
façon équitable éthique est il y avait
une justice sociale vocal famille c'est
pas comme aujourd'hui où il ya des
familles démunies stan tshosane on est
enfin non pas de grandes chances pour se
changer un drame
c'est bien
[Musique]
là
fauve pas affreux folk affreux sauvage
pas plus personne ne devrait porter cela
sauf pour le tournage d'un film
en vérité je ne veux pas comparer la rda
avec le troisième reich
mais la rda était un chapitre sombre
dans l'histoire allemande dea
cela ne doit plus jamais se reproduire
me
[Musique]
hans günther eagle incarne la
schizophrénie de l'allemagne réunifiée
il est né à l'est mais il a grandi à
l'ouest car si parents voulaient
l'élever loin du communisme il aime son
village de l'est où ils retournaient
tous les étés voir sa famille mais il
déteste la rda dont il collectionne
pourtant les objets et les symboles plus
de 6600 reliques accumulé frénétiquement
lors de ses visites annuelles
tous ces objets car je les trouvais
vraiment très moche la
en allemagne de l'ouest on avait déjà
cela en
1959 non une scène d'action rda il avait
les mêmes en 1985 par cycleurope écharpe
stratège que ça rebute les et
collectionner car j'étais sûr qu'un jour
la rda n'existerait plus sereine dans un
tel pays avec une économie aussi
lamentable on ne pouvait pas exister
éternellement exc
[Musique]
mocek ce qu'il fallait six semaines pour
faire développer les négatifs et les
photos couleur ne gardait pas les
couleurs photo stallone dans l'hérault
fera beau
tous
hans günther ringer est revenu habiter à
l'est dans la maison de son enfance il a
voulu exposer sa collection aux
habitants de son village mais ces objets
que lui trouve s'il est peu les trouvais
beau
déçu il a rangé sa collection rogner
[Musique]
les gens se moquaient de moi me disait
vous ne savez rien de la rda car vous
avez vécu pendant quarante ans en
allemagne de l'ouest
je leur répondais que je la connaissais
mieux qu'eux car j'avais traversé la
frontière que n'avait jamais traversée
c'était le pire le côté le plus inhumain
la rda on n'y a pas traité comme un être
humain par apple et d'aider à vabre la
rda était la plus grande prison du monde
on ne pouvait pas en sortir sans être
tué onnaing a choisi sauvergues
des spécialistes of nodes
[Musique]
qui ne doit pas être sous
ce pays prison avait ses gardiens les
agents de la stasi la police politique
rien qu'à berlin est ils étaient 58 pour
un million d'habitants la stasi pouvait
entrer chez vous fouiller votre intimité
briser votre vie vous envoyer en prison
pour un simple soupçon de dissidence
la prison de roanne xiaozhun n'était
indiquée sur aucune carte de berlin est
un trou noir où la stasi enfermait les
dissidents et les candidats à
l'immigration reinhardt fuhrmann a été
emprisonné ici de longs mois en 1972
jeune étudiant il avait tenté en vain de
fuir la rda
aujourd'hui les guides il fait visiter
la prison à un groupe de lycéens venus
d'une petite ville de l'ex rda
200 cellules exiguës des lits en bois
des prisonniers soumis à une torture
psychologique
systématique
[Musique]
vous savez qu'on surnomme berlin une
mère de maison
nous les prisonniers on disait qu ici on
était dans le sous marin au fond de
cette mer
comme dans un sous marin on éteignait
jamais la lumière les cellules étaient
toujours éclairés
[Musique]
on
quand j'étais en prison j'ai pris du
poids à cause du manque de lumière du
jour et du manque de mouvement
j'en suis sorti boursouflé avec la peau
toute blanche
on pouvait se lever on pouvait bouger un
peu mais il n'était pas question de
grands mouvements on n'était pas
question de faire des pompes par exemple
c'était interdit
moi je me demande toujours pourquoi
dirigeants ont fui d'autres parce je
voudrais comprendre pourquoi avant la
construction du mur deux millions de
personnes sont parties
pourquoi vous est il absolument fuir
le problème c'est que les profs qui ont
vécu cette époque pense que nous savons
déjà tout alors qu'on ne l'a pas vécu et
on ne sait rien tout à fait c'est pareil
avec nos parents il n'en parle pas parce
qu'ils pensent que c'est super
ça
c'est un film
beaucoup de gens qui ressemble de
l'ostalgie se rappelle du temps de leur
belle jeunesse zone fois de l'époque où
il était en bonne santé
il en oublie tout
je comprends ça moi aussi j'aimerais
bien retrouver ma jeunesse
mais sinon je pense que la rda est une
expérience dont l'allemagne aurait
vraiment pu se passer et le monde aussi
d'ailleurs
irish en état
[Musique]
la rda appartient maintenant à
l'histoire comme et riche année coeur
son dernier dirigeant nord peu après la
réunification
[Musique]
triesman son sosie le ressuscite
durant toute sa vie à l'est il n'aurait
jamais osé limitée le tout puissant
secrétaire général d'un parti communiste
auquel lui-même a toujours refusé
d'adhérer
aujourd'hui à la télévision ou lors de
soirées eu nostalgique il offre à necker
une seconde carrière dans un parti
révolutionnaire
le parti de l'humour
ss nature et son fils bien sûr beaucoup
de choses en rda n'était pas comme elles
auraient dû être
mais
malgré mes nombreux déboires c'est phil
rudd schleck je ne ressens aucune envie
vengeance de bulles
[Musique]
d'air
austral
[Musique]
chinois qui réplique
ma mère
là
on a
[Applaudissements]
un papa
mahaney
[Musique]
ouais